like i i have an antiva flag on my on my
wall um and a student complained about
that and you said it made them feel
uncomfortable well this is meant to make
fascists feel uncomfortable so if you
feel uncomfortable i i don't really know
what to tell you i don't think this guy
has any right to stay out of prison i
don't there of course there's going to
be terrorism in afghanistan there's
going to be terrorism in pakistan
pakistan there's going to be terrorism
in yemen there's going to be terrorism
in africa there's going to be terrorism
and a lot of different places okay and
we are going to have to be smart about
how you fight it when you fight at what
you do there is terror at home okay
do you remember last year
when blm and antifa
terrorists burned the country down city
to city to city
targeting civilians to achieve political
ends right the most basic definition of
terrorism when they did that
and they did that with the encouragement
and sometimes financial support of
elected democrats one of whom is now the
vice president of the united states
remember that so these antifa guys these
blm guys they're not just running in the
streets throwing molotov cocktails into
people's store windows
they're also in the classroom james
o'keefe over project veritas
has an undercover interview with a
member of antifa
who is a teacher at a school in
sacramento
who who doesn't even hide it it turns
out he actually flies an antifa flag in
the classroom i have 180 days to turn
him into revolutionaries how do you do
that how do you scare me
sacramento organization that is under
the banner of antipas is very loosely
organized right um so like yeah when
when there is like right wing rallies
and stuff then we like
we'll create an opposition to that yeah
beautiful where would he go to
connect with some of these organizations
like
i post calendar every week and then so
like
and i do it for extra credit so they get
points for doing it like so that
encourages them to do it and i've had
like students show like protests
community events you know tabling
food distribution all sorts of sorts of
things they when they go they take
pictures they write up a reflection
that's their extra credit like i have an
antiva flag on my on my wall um and a
student complained about that and you
said it made them feel uncomfortable
well this is meant to make fascists feel
uncomfortable so if you feel
uncomfortable i i don't really know what
to feel like
maybe you shouldn't be aligning with the
values that this is antithetical too
yeah maybe maybe you shouldn't support
america for instance right you shouldn't
salute the american flag you shouldn't
support the american president when it
was donald trump
uh you shouldn't you shouldn't do that
if you do that
well i guess you're just not going to
align with our class right
yesterday i mentioned the teacher who
has her students say the pledge of
allegiance to the pride flag the pride
progress flag that's the new one with
even more colors and it's like sex and
race and whatever we'll get to her in a
second there is an update on her
she is like uncle sam
compared to this guy she's like george
patton for goodness sakes compared to
this guy i said with her that she should
be fired but she shouldn't be thrown in
jail she shouldn't be ostracized this
guy
i don't know i think we should get a
little tougher with this guy i don't
think i like william f buckley jr
founder of the post-war conservative
movement i don't think this guy has any
right to stay out of prison i don't i
certainly he should be fired he should
not be teaching but i if you're a member
of antifa i don't think you really have
a right to stay out of prison i don't
think you really have many rights at all
if you're a member of a terrorist
organization that openly seeks to
overturn our system of government and
that has actively engaged in acts of
terror and regularly does that
i don't think you have very many rights
at all
today you do i mean today you're you're
much more protected than the average
trump supporter
in the public square in the sort of
activism you can engage in but i don't
think that should be the case and i
think conservatives need to get a little
bit tougher in the way that we write the
law and enforce the law and the way we
engage in politics
i'm glad you like that vid i need you to
do me a favor one for two favors okay
one leave a comment
whatever i don't care what the comment
is just leave it you know hey michael
nice hair man i say what's going on
michael thank you for doing that second
take out your phone
open up your podcast app here i'll get
mine up open up your podcast app
go to the okay whatever apple podcast or
spotify or stitch or whatever click it
okay you're there all right type in the
michael knowles show
all right you got it search you see
they're probably going to suppress the
results but you know what the show is
you click it
click
i subscribe that appreciate you thank
you
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]